I'm Uta Francke, I'm a human geneticist originally
from Germany, as you can hear, and I
am an Emeritus Professor here at Stanford and
also Senior Medical Director at 23 and me.
>> well thank you very much for being here. we've been talking
a lot and learning a lot about the genome, what it's made
of, and right now, we've been focusing on how big it is.
And, We, we've learned that there are about 3 billion base pairs in
the human genome. And there's a lot of research that's gone on
for a long time. And we're hoping, you can maybe, shed some
light on what we know about the research that led to us
understanding how big the genome is. And sort of, where we are now.
>> You know there were early estimates of the size of
the genome simply by the, measuring the amount of DNA in
a cell? People could do that a long time ago, and
so the estimate was in that range of 3 billion base pairs.
But the idea to actually sequence it was, came up in the mid 80s,
when capillary sequencing was developed, and many people thought it was
a, absolutely crazy idea, because it's so huge, so much information. And
it was also known that there was a lot
of repetitive DNA in it. So people said, is it
really worth it to, to find the genes that
are really important in this huge, huge amount of information?
But then when it was agreed upon to embark on it as an international venture,
it was also decided that we were not going to do just the human, we also
wanted to do model organisms that people work
on, in the laboratory. Like the roundworms, the
fruit fly. And then to compare the human
and the animal information at the same time.
>> And at that time,
we already knew that the relative genome sizes of
these different animals were, were different, at the time, right?
>> Yeah, that was already known. And, the other thing to know
about the Human Genome Project, when it finally got started around 1990,
the first five years were devoted to just mapping the chromosomes. You
know, people heard about chromosomes, and we know that DNA runs in chromosomes
from one end to another, so it
would make sense, logical sense, to start sequencing
at one end and then go through. But instead, what people did, they made maps
of the chromosomes and then you could focus in on specific region and it was
a sequencing there. And also to find
genes that are located on specific chromosome regions.
>>
[INAUDIBLE]
So, instead of having those sort of, like you
say, sequence from one end to the other, you
could have many starting places in the middle of
a chromosome and sort of read out from there.
>> Right, and you could relate the sequence to the chromosome and
features because chromosomes, when they are
treated with a certain agent, display
banding patterns that are very unique.
Therefore, we can identify each chromosome
individually, which is something you cannot do when they are uniformly stained,
and also we can see within each chromosome there are
certain regions. And now we can find out in which
region certain genes are located. And all of this physical
mapping, as it's called, was done before the sequencing even started.
>> So what happened when the sequencing
project started? You mentioned it was an
international collaboration. Was this really countries all
over the world, or were they more
from one region or another?
>> Well there were countries who had developed
infrastructure to take on such a big project.
And in Europe it was predominantly the UK,
France and Germany. And Canada was a player
as well as Japan and China. And all
of these people got together under the, chairmanship
so to say, of Francis Collins who is
now the Director of the NIH. He was organizing
this big international thing and made sure
there wasn't too much waste and duplication. They
were dividing up the chromosomes, like here you
do chromosome 21, okay, that's where we're focusing
on. And then they had regular meetings.
They exchanged information. All the results were immediately
shared and put online. And therefore because of
this international effort this led to success ultimately.
>> And this obviously took a period of, of time. and I
imagine it sort of was stop and go. At different times. You know how.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> How does this fit? You know the, this big initial effort to
sequence it. as far as a time scale. How long did it take?
>> Well, we started in 1990. And for the
first five years they did just mapping. And then
it was slow to get seriously into sequencing. It
was estimated that it would be finished in 2005.
But then in the late 90s there was
also a commercial company called Celera. They said we
can do this even faster, you guys are
just too slow. We have better methods. And we
can chop up the genome in small sequences
and sequence the small pieces and have the computers
line it all up and put it together. And
that's when a serious way started because the companies
threatened that whatever genes they would discover,
they would patent, and therefore the medical benefits
would go to them rather than to the
public. And therefore, in 2000, both of them,
the International Consortium and the company announced
that they had a draft sequence of the
human genome. This draft was very imperfect. It
was full of holes, full of mistakes and
then the International Consortium spend another three years to finishing it
up. So, in 2003 then they said, okay, mission accomplished. Here is.
>> You have the, you have a draft.
Now where are we now with sequencing the human
genome? Or many human genomes. Are we multiple drafts
beyond? And are we reaching out to many people.
>> Yes. See the original genome that was sequenced in the company.
It was mostly the company CEO Quake Winters
genome. But the international effort had many different people
involved. So the genome was a composite of
sequences of many individuals. And that's called the reference
genome. But what you really want to know
is, what is different between the genomes of different
people who live in different parts of the
world? And that was the next effort. And to,
to really sequence individuals was known ethnic background and
find out what are the variations between humans and that's
when it really became interesting. And that took another
ten years to become really useful to have that information.
>>
So, what does the size of a genome mean? Does it mean anything at all?
>> Well there are some organisms with huge genomes, like
the salamanders, you know? And what is all that sequence, it's probably has no
information or content. Sometimes genomes get big because viruses get in, and
they replicate. They make copies of themselves. And that has no useful function.
So there is only a smaller part of the genome that's really important because
it has function. And this is something
we're still working on unraveling as a function.
>> That was beautiful. I think that's all I want to ask about genome size.
>> Okay, yeah.
>> So now, as a natural segue-way,
we're going to pick up into the coding regions.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And I'm going to let you say all of it. I'm just going to try to set
you up, and then just let you talk
about it, and I'll just ask follow-up questions.
>> You can, you can go back and forth. More, more dialogue
>> Oh, sure.
>> Is fine with me.
>> Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's fine But you're
doing a great job talking. So, like telling the story.
>> Yeah, but I don't want to lecture, you know.
[LAUGH]
>> But that's okay. I mean, that's sort of the the idea of the interview
[CROSSTALK]
even here is. I want you to, to be free
to tell the story. but I'll definitely ask questions here.
>> Okay.
>>
so, we have 3 billion base pairs, in just one
copy of the human genome. And we, we've learned that.
You know, we have two copies of the human genome,
of the nuclear genome in, in ourselves and we've been
learning a bit about the coding regions, the protein coding
regions. what, what can you tell us about the relative
size of the protein coding regions of the genome versus
the sort of non-coding regions? this was of course a motivation
to start it. We want to find out all protein coding
genes because these are the ones initially considered the most important part.
And as you know, the protein coding genes
are dividing into exons and introns and only
the exons have the actual information for the
amino acids. Has this been covered in the course?
>>
>> Yesterday.
>> Okay.
>> Well, hold on, actually, hold on, let me, let me think for a second.
>>
[CROSSTALK]
>> No, this is lesson three.
>> Okay, okay, so we don't know that yet. Okay, so the big question was
how many protein coding genes are there in
the genome. And initially, before the genome project
[INAUDIBLE].
The number that's been kicked around was, like, a 100,000.
>> Mm hm.
>> Sort of a wild guess. And then, between 2000 and
2003, there was an official betting game going on. Where people
could put down a dollar and a number. And then, years
later, it was $5, and then it was $20. Because it
[INAUDIBLE]
became more difficult. And everybody could only put
down one bet. About 150 people put down a
bet. And their range, the ranges of their guesses
went from, you wouldn't believe it. 25,000 to 150,000.
>> Wow.
>> So nobody had really any good idea. The mean was
around 61,000 genes. And when the first draft was published, they said,
why, we had a brief look at it, and we think it's within 30 and 35,000. And when
it was finally finished, the number had come down to 20 to 25,000. And
many people were surprised, because this is hardly
any more than the roundworm, or the fruit
fly. So the humans are so much more
complex. Shouldn't they have more protein coding genes?
>> Right.
>> But there was a mechanism.
How you can make many proteins from one
gene. And this is called alternative splicing. You are
going to get to this later in the course.
That means you can take bits and pieces from
one gene and you put them together differently,
and then they encode different proteins. So the complexity
cannot be immediately, deduced from the number of genes
when you don't know what these, these genes can
be used for.
>> What percentage of the genome is
actually made up of coding region, roughly?
>> It's only 1 to 2%. And, so all this other,
you know, 90, 98% to 99% then, I mean, a lot
of people who, you know, are just learning about the genome
may be wondering, what exactly is the rest of that sequence doing?
>> You see, originally people thought it was just junk!
It was just a virus getting in and replicating itself.
And in recent years, people started to look. At how much of that sequence is
being made into RNA? How much is being transcribed? And to everyone's surprise,
more than 80% is actually made into a copy of RNA. And these
RNAs have all kinds of interesting functions. For example, to
regulate activity of other genes. To regulate the activity
of messenger RNAs, how they are being
translated, and many different functions that they always
have. Some of them are structural, I mean,
there are RNAs that has structural components of
[UNKNOWN].
And otherwise, outside of the coding sequence, there are control
regions that are important to regulate the activity of each gene.
>> I see. So, we learn in this lesson
about messenger RNA, mRNA. And so what you're saying,
there are actually other kinds of RNAs that can
be made besides mRNA that doesn't get turned into protein?
>> That's right. And what was found out
recently, that you remember, there are two strands in
the DNA, and the messenger RNA's only made
of one strand, that gives the formation for the
protein. But what is being found out now is
that there are antisense RNAs, that actually other strand
of DNA can also be made into RNA. It
goes in the opposite direction. It has no coding
function for proteins, usually not, sometimes it does. But
it has regulatory function. And you just can't imagine
if a gene is transcribed in the other direction, then
the transcription of the messenger RNA has a problem, you know.
It runs into, it's a train wreck, quite So there's a
regulation of gene activity by anti sense RNAs. That's one mechanism.
>> Right, so it sounds like, maybe some of
the complexity of different species or the complexity of cells
is in, part not so much the, the share
of content the number of genes you have, but maybe.
How you regulate all of those genes together to, to create something.
>> What we are finding out now is that the genomic regions communicate
with each other. Like you can have an enhancer region that is downstream away
from the gene, or even in an intron of another gene. But then folds over,
communicates with the promoter, and sets in motion the messenger RNA synthesis.
So the whole genome is three-dimensional, it's
not just one dimensional series of letters. It
is a lot of. Three dimensional arrangement
and interaction that's very important for its function.
>> We'll actually talk a lot, or a little bit
more about that in lesson four, hopefully. You mentioned axon
and entrons which are part of mRNAs, and the axons
are the coding regions. The actual parts that get turned into
protein and we seem to have, learned in our little time spent with the material
that the exon seem much smaller in general than the introns. The introns seem
to be very big a lot of times. do we know anything about the,
the size of exons and introns and sort of. How or why that, that exists?
>> There was a huge variation in the intron size. Some can be very small,
and some can be absolutely huge. And we don't know exactly why that is. The last
exon is usually larger than the other exons because it contains. The signatures
stop, and then it's the untranslated region,
which is important for regulatory purposes. And, introns
in the middle of the gene, they can be tiny, or can be bigger, and
we don't know exactly, I don't understand why it evolved this way.
>> So, what are we still learning, in
general, about the genome, and the coding, and
the non-coding regions? are there any. Really important
concepts or new findings that you think are
really interesting that we're learning about, either the
size of the genome or not so much
the size but the number of coding regions,
the amount of coding region, how it interacts.
>> What
we're learning about the genome is more about
the function of the non-coding regions. You know,
there are, for example, small nuclear RNAs. These
are small RNAs that are part of a, part
of the nucleus that are encoded in intron.
And they are encoded in intron. When the
intron is degraded, these little RNAs are released
and they have very important functions in the body.
And this was found out like, every research we
did in our lab, when we compared the human and
the mouse. The exon sequences did not code for protein,
and they were not at all conserved. And the intron
sequences were conserved, because that's where the functional units are
located. So there're all kind of surprises. You know, you
shouldn't only think the exon's important, the intron is junk
and gets thrown away. Now it can be the opposite.
>> you
also mentioned repetitive DNA when you were talking about some of I guess
the historical context of the genome and even once we sequenced it. If
anyone does any research on their own they might find that there's still
a lot of repetitive regions. What do we know about those in the genome?
>> in most of them are just remnants, I mean they were copies made of
some early viral intruder and now they are
degenerated. They are bits and pieces of them,
but there were still some active copies, and what
they can do, they can still make copies of
themselves, and they can jump around and insert someplace
else in the genome. And actually cause problems. They can
cause disease by inserting into an important protein coding
genes. So we are not done with dealing with
all these repetitive sequences. They're still changing, and that
means there is huge variability from one person to another,
as well.
>> I think that's an amazing concept, too, to think about our genomes.
We sort of think of them as, okay, we have this static genome.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And it may interact with itself to create a protein, or
regulation, but. The genome itself is changing even today, like you said, these
[CROSSTALK]
moving elements.
>>
[CROSSTALK]
It's still evolving.
>> Well, what of I just maybe, oh, so,
when people talk about variation in the human genome.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We often times talk about single nucleotide variants, which we'll come
to in, in later lessons for, for our course. Is that the main
kind of variation that exists in the human genome, are these single
letter differences, or there are other
kinds of variations that are important too?
>> We have identified
about 15 million single letter differences, so by
sheer number, they are the most common. But then
there are other varients, they are called copy
number variations. Where whole chunks of the genome can
be repeated, and they can be present in
these two, three or many copies. And there are
differences between human beings. So some people have
two copies, some have five, some may have 12.
And if you look at the total number
of nucleotides involved in those. Then this is
more common. So the individual copy number variance
or CNV.'s are fewer than the ones we have
identified for SNVs. But if you look at
the amount of genomic sequence and worked in this
type of what's called structural variation it, it
involves the larger part of the genome. I see,
so between single nucleotide variance and copy number variation.
those are the two main kinds, or the two main forms of variations in humans.
>> Yeah, then there are others like inversions where certain pieces of
the genome can be turned around and some people and not in others.
>> And even Translocations? How viable are
translocations, and do they get propagated at
all in a population over time, or are most translocations inviable?
>> Well, we find them in families. You
know, there are balanced translocations, where a piece
of a chromosome is taken off and hooked
somewhere else, or two pieces have been exchanged. And
as long as they are balanced meaning that
the right number of genes is there, people are
fine. They wouldn't know about it, unless a
break is in a gene but that's pretty unusual.
The break is most often in a repetitive
sequence. But then when these people may have
children because of what happens in myosis, the
chromosomes align and cross over. It's possible that a
child inherits a chromosome that only has an
extra copy, and does then get the other one
that's missing something. Then you have an unbalanced
translocation, and that can cause very bad developmental defects
intellectual, def, deficits. These are the children who we see in
the clinic, and we look at their chromosomes. And look at
their parents and we see that translocation has been passed on
through several generations already. But otherwise
they don't last in, in population.
>> Well, you were just touching on something that I want to us to
move on and talk about for lesson 12 now. I want to know a bit
more about your background and your experience. You
have a lot of experience with human genetics and
both in research but also clinically. looking at
families and individuals with various phenotypes. I'd like for
you to start maybe tell us when you
first fell in love with genetics and when you
started studying and sort of your journey to where
you are today as a, as a Stanford professor.
>> I went to medical school in Germany,
and then I trained in pediatrics. I came to this country to train at Los
Angeles Children's Hospital. And then I had to think about what else to do, and
what I really wanted to do was
endocrinology because I love biochemistry. I thought biochemistry
was the best thing in medical school. But I couldn't get in as a foreign medical
[INAUDIBLE].
And genetics was just in the beginning, starting
to get interesting. It was at the time
where it became possible to identify chromosomes by
chromosome banding. And there weren't many people going
into that field. Which had a great advantage
because as a fellow at UCLA in human
genetics I was allowed to do anything. I
could learn chromosomes, biochemical genetics as well as see
the patients on the wards where people said, oh what
is this my formation, is it a syndrome, is it genetic,
will it happen again? So the training involved from the beginning,
clinical genetics and then as a sub sub specialties of genetics.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Well, I was going to say so did you, were you able to interact
in, in, in, I guess, medical school and beyond as you were sort of discovering
the area that you were sort of going to focus on for, for genetics. At
the same time were you able to experience the clinical side of genetics as well?
>> All the time. I was active in
clinical genetics for the last 30 something years.
>> And what does that involve exactly?
>> Well, in pediatrics you're mostly focused
on children having problems. So either children
who inherit something. Or children who get
very sick after they are born, because
they cannot metabolize protein, there's something wrong
in their metabolism. Or children who have
certain birth defects, children who don't do
well in school, who are late walking,
who are late aquiring skills or have
neurological symptoms. Seizures. So all kinds of problems
that people didn't know, what is this? So there was a lot of discovery to
do. We found out that certain clinical
phenotypes were associated with chromosomal duplications or deletions,
now that we could look at chromosomes in
higher resolution. So that was a first stage
[INAUDIBLE]
or in the 70s, make discoveries this way.
And now, of course, whole genome sequencing is
applied to these children. And when nobody had,
could figure out what caused their problem, you look
at the whole sequence, and you can find
a change. And that's been very successful in the
last couple years. Since high, high throughput sequencing
methods were developed. So, the exiting thing about my
own career is a two-way street. It's always been
two ways between the clinic and the laboratory. You see
somebody fascinating in the clinic, and you bring samples to
the lab, and you tell your PhDs. Look this is
what the patients look like and we have to
figure out what's going on here, and that gets everybody
motivated. When you learn something in the lab, you find
a gene like we found a gene for Rett Syndrome.
And then you can figure out, can we do anything to help these patients now
that we have the gene. We figure out it's function. In the last few years, we
spent a lot of time making mouse
models, because we looked at diseases that involved
the central nervous system, and you can't go
into a human brain and take a sample.
>> I'm sure there are many ethical concerns there.
>> I mean some people have part of
the brain removed because of some medical indication, and
then of course you can get it, but what
we did make mouse models, because the genome is
very conserved between the human and the mouse. And,
even though we're working with deletion syndromes, where part of
a chromosome is missing, we can define where in
the mouse genome that part is located. It's got the
same genes in it. Take it out in the
mouse, and then you have mice that you can study
the development, prenatally.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Afterwards, take the brain, cut it up, look at what's going
on, and this is what we did mostly in, while in this millennium
[LAUGH]
I would say.
>>
[LAUGH]
Well, it sounds like, I mean this is good,
good old-fashioned science. Really good science. And, to people who
aren't familiar, it sounds like detective work. You, you
sort of establish what you see. You make an observation
>> Mm-hm
>> And then you go investigate. I'm, I'm really struck by, even
still, by the idea that the human and the mouse phenome are similar
enough that you're even able to do that. Can you speak for a
second about, you know, working in
genetics, especially with human genetics, where there
>> Mm hmm
>> Are so many
limitations, about the constraints, but also the tools you
have to answer certain questions, for people who may
not be familiar with the idea that the mouse
and the human genome are in fact quite similar.
>> Well, the mouse is such a useful organism because mouse genetics
has developed parallel to human genetics.
And many mutations and phenotypes were spontaneously
already detected in the mouse, so you already
knew there was a mouse model for this disease,
and you could go and study it right away.
And for those where they did not arrive spontaneously,
the mouse is ideal because you can manipulate
the embryonic stem cells. You could introduce mutations in
the mouse that you know exist in the human.
Therefore you make a mouse model that exactly replicates,
biochemically what's in the human. The mice
don't always have the same phenotypes, obviously,
because they have a much smaller brain
and many other differences. Right, but they're similar
enough that when you look at those
differences or the what happens when you change
the genetics of the mouse you can then adapt that back to the clinic sometimes.
>> Well sure. You can also use the mouse to
try out any drugs that you may come up with.
Any ideas you have for treatment, you can give it
to the mouse and see whether there is an effect.
>>
So, in, in, in your time, in your
clinical and, and research experience, what what area
did you focus on more specifically? What, what
would you say is your, your general research subject?
>> There were too many to mention. I really
started out with whatever was possible to do at the
time. You know, I was, in a way, driven
by technology that was being developed, and I saw where
this technology could be applied to the
problem. So it started with cytogenetics. In the
area of banding chromosomes, that was in
the 70's. And then biochemical genetics, somatic cell
genetics, meaning that you can fuse cells
from different organisms and you can. Map chromosomes.
So in the beginning of the genome project,
we were very much invested in mapping genes
to chromosomal regions. With the idea, if you have a gene that's been
cloned, and you know the function, you map it to a chromosome region, where
we already know a certain disease gene has been mapped. Then becomes a candidate
gene for this disease. And that was a useful approach in the early 90s.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then, as all these other technologies
became available to study global gene expression patterns and
doing mouse modeling, and we, then we moved to
studying individual diseases, like Rett Syndrome. And Roberts Syndrome,
[UNKNOWN]
Syndrome and ultimately I thought the deletion syndromes
where you take out a chunk of chromosome,
and would be interesting because there are many
different genes in there, and which of these genes
contribute to what part of the phenotype? I
found that fascinating. And that's, Was the project we
were working on in the end. So it's
a step wise process of discovery that makes use
of the technology as it is being developed.
So you can say it's opportunistic. Yes, it
is. Ultimately my goal was always to find
some treatment for some of these genetic diseases
that we see in the clinic. What was one of your most exciting or fun discoveries
in research, or in the clinic. Do you have a favorite idea or time or story?
>> Yeah the most exciting was this
new RNA, this small nuclear RNA that are in introns. Because this is a syndrome
called Prader–Willi syndrome. And what it looks
like is that children are born very floppy
and very difficult to feed. And what
happens after a while, they get stronger and
they start eating, and everybody is happy.
Finally, Jimmy eats his food. And they start
eating too much. And they become massively obese, if
you don't watch it, in no time. So the
problem was, what is going on with these children?
And we, we tried to make a mouse to
find out the deletion was quite large, four and
a half megabases, several genes in it. And we
found out there's many different things I can't explain
in this short time. But that it's actually the
[UNKNOWN]
that is responsible. We made a mouse model, taking out just the
from the introns. And these mice, they don't get obese, but they
don't stop eating. So it's the signal that tells you, I had enough.
It's a satiety signal. That's missing. The children, they don't eat very
fast. They just keep eating, keep eating. The mice do the same thing.
>> So you were able to essentially
sort of discover the genetic underpinning of that.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Is there any treatment that
you were able to do anything with from medicine?
>> Many people are now working on this.
We made the mice. We let them, we distribute
them to everybody who works on obesity. I mean,
you can imagine If you figure out how this
[UNKNOWN]
is. What are the genes they are actually
regulating? What are the mechanisms of action for the
[UNKNOWN]?
We don't know that yet. And so we hope
that ultimately a treatment will come out not only
for this rare condition called Prader Willi Syndrome, but
maybe for people who have a problem with appetite.
[INAUDIBLE].
>> What do you think is the most
difficult part of your research that you've done,
in general speaking, for maybe, research in general?
What do you think is the most difficult part?
>> Okay, not technologically difficult but in terms of managing
and handling. Yeah. The most difficult part is if you
feel you get unfair reviews, if there is competition with things going on
in the background. You know, reviews of papers and
grants are anonymous. And so you sometimes get reviews back
that you think are totally unfair. And there's nothing
you can do. You don't know, who's shooting from where.
>> Right,
[INAUDIBLE].
>> So that is the hardest part. Collaborations with people you know, you
can manage. You know, you can, sometimes they go sour, but at least
you know the person. You can sit down and say, hey, let's straighten
this out. We had a difference and now we are friends again, right?
>> Exactly.
[LAUGH]
>> And, if it's anonymous, You don't can only defend yourself.
>> Sort of off camera or on camera, I know
there are a lot of people who are pushing for
to make peer review not anonymous because.
>> Oh yeah.
>> They want it to be, so that you can actually, you
know call someone else and say, hey. That wasn't a far review.
>> It, it, it's much more constructive.
>> Yeah.
>> So for example, I worked for a journal called Peer J. Peer, P, E, E, R, J.
It's an open access journal. Where the people who agree to review,
agree to make it, make themselves known. And then the whole correspondence
between the reviewers and the original manuscript. And
then the revision and everything is going to be online.
So people can actually learn what happened during this
review. And how did this reviewer improved the paper?
>> Mm-hm.
>> So the reviews you get back are. Really constructive, they give you
all kinds of good ideas, what else you can do to make it better.
>> Right. so does thinking about what
you do as a career what do you think the future is for people who
are interested in being clinicians, and bridging the
gap between you know, people and the research
that can help them? Do you think there's going to be a. A bigger opening in,
in the future for people who want to do something similar to, to what you do?
>> Mm-hm. While there was definitely a need, and there are many opportunities.
But the drawbacks are, in genetics for example,
we don't have enough people coming into medical genetics
out of the medicine side. Because, in genetics, you
don't make any money. We don't have procedures. We
don't stick tubes into people that we can
charge for. It's all cognitive. You know, you spend
a lot of time going through complicated information. Searching
the literature. Sitting down with the family counseling room.
You don't get reimbursed much for this.
>> Sure.
>> And therefore it's not attractive, not if, not for people who went
to American Medical Schools and to enter a career as a medical geneticist.
So we have a shortage and many of the most successful people are
foreign trained. Medical, medical doctors who
don't have pay for their medical education.
>> We hopefully have a real large international audience you
know, participating in our course. What would you say to a
student or in a lifetime learner who's watching and is really
interested in the subject, and they'd even be interested in thinking
about this as a career. What advice would you give them?
>> I mean, I can only say this has been a lifetime
learning experience to be part of genetics during those decades when everything
developed and we are not done yet. I think it goes on
and will be even more exciting. There are many secrets in the
genome that are yet to be unraveled. And
both PhDs and MDs should consider this. And then
genetic counseling, that's a whole new career path. We
have a training program here at Stanford for genetic
counselors, the masters program. Because you don't have
to have a PhD or an MD to tell
people, this is what we found in your sequence,
and this is what it means. And these people
are trained specifically to do that. And we'll need a ton of them. Lots
of them. So I want to encourage people to consider this as a career.
>> Great.
that's all the questions I have. Do you
want to talk about your affiliation with 23 and
me at all? Or do you want to just, sort of, leave it as the Stanford connection.
>> I think I'd rather do this as a Stanford now. Uh-huh.
>> Let's do that. Well, I'll open up to you, is there
anything else, either about the genome subjects or about, you know, doing
[INAUDIBLE]
genetics research.
>> If you ask me on
[UNKNOWN]
that would be another half an hour because as a lot's
going on at 23 and me, I find exciting and why did
I decide to work with them and how long have I worked
with them and so. Should, you know, want a part of this.
>> Is there anything else about the genome or the
genome size? Anything I'd love to know, like when you teach
genetics in the classroom. What do you, what do you say
to students to get them excited about, genetics and the genome.
>> what student,
what students find exciting is often the applied part. You
know bioengineering. Now that we find out the things about plants and, and what
can we do to improve food supply for the world, bio genetic, bio, bio, engineo
genetic, bioengineering. And also making models for diseases. This is
the mice I just used as a matter
of convenience because they're already genetically well studied organisms.
The smallest mammal. But you would much rather
have larger organisms, and now they're being able to
make whole organs of the pig, for example. In, in vitro more or less. I mean all
of this development are exciting. So I talk about
induced pro importance stem cells. How you can make.
Different set types and organs from
[UNKNOWN],
and how you can study diseases in a dish, you know, if the patient was
Parkinson's disease, we can take a skin
biopsy, make the cells into neurons, and then
study the mechanism that, in the brain,
gives these people Parkinson's disease. And those other
side of the genome itself, I talk
about repetitive sequences and they find this boring.
[LAUGH]
>>
That's exciting. yeah I was going to say, I
find that the, the evolution of the genome itself
is just fascinating, and I'm really intrigued by how
people use genetic information to look back in time.
to sort of look at connections, my, I, the lab I,
in undergrad I worked in a yeast, a yeast lab, and
was really interested in the bio-genetics of specifically the
RNA, the C-terminal domain of RNA plurase two, it's very conserved, from yeast.
>> You know there's no RNAs
[UNKNOWN]
have it already.
[CROSSTALK]
Yeah, these are ancient. You know, there
wasn't RNA world before DNA even came in existence.
>> Yeah, I know, it's fascinating, and I think maybe something,
I do want to get this on camera. as a geneticist, human or otherwise,
how do you know something's important? Is it the fact that you see it conserved
in many different species? Or is there something else that, that goes
on that tells you, okay this sequence or this event is really important?
>>
[INAUDIBLE]
Finds what you think is important. If you're
interested in the evolution, then anything that traces
back to a lower organism and is conserved
is, is interesting. Or changes through evolution are
interesting, because then you can understand the underpinning
of evolution. But if you want to find
out what makes humans so special. Why do
we have language? Why do we have ethical considerations?
Then you look for something that you only find in humans and
not in, in other organisms. So it depends what's interesting to you?
[BLANK_AUDIO]